[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: As we continue
to see our world being utterly
transformed by
accelerating technologies,
extending our capacities to
exercise our will in the world,
one of the questions
that keeps coming up
is, so what is
the future of sex?
If you think of
communication technologies
as expressing a desire
for inter-subjectivity,
a desire for telepathy,
a desire to become one
through an act of
communication as consummation.
Right?
To share subjectivities
with one another.
This is expressed by technology,
and this is connected again,
to the idea of sex.
To lose yourself
and find yourself,
when dissolving the ego in
the hands of somebody else.
The orgasm, as ultimate
little death, but also
resurrection, right?
To become more
than whole, right?
To literally have
all of your desires
abolished by the plenitude
of their satisfaction,
as Roland Barthes writes about.
So what is the future?
Virtual reality, environments
that stimulate all your nerve
endings and your sexy
sensors in your body?
Pornography that
arrests your capacity
to lose yourself in fantasy,
but maybe plot and execution
akin to an art film?
Maybe we'll create settings that
are romantic, so it's not just
the sex act, but the sex context
that will be packaged and sold
to us in manufactured
dreamscapes that
are better than any movie
you've ever watched,
better than any romantic
comedy you've ever seen.
To lose yourself in "Breakfast
at Tiffany's," for this
to be the future of sex.
The future of sex is real
virtualities, virtual realities
in which we can lose ourselves,
in which our wildest dreams
and desires can be expressed
in a kaleidoscopic ecstasy.
A multi-colored frenzy
of orgasms and mindgasms.
And man, it's going to transform
sexuality in ways we cannot
even fathom.
Rubbing our bodies
up against each other
in the desire for
the sublime is going
to be merely seen as
a faint memory, right?
Back in the days, when
we had to do that.
I think what's next will
go way beyond, amplifying.
Just yeah, amplifying
our capacity
to satiate our desires.
[MUSIC PLAYING]